when you look at the big questions of
humanity of
hate
War
what else is there evil
maybe there's the positive aspects of
that of meaning of love
what is the fact that
reality is an illusion
perceived what what is the conscious
realism
when applied to daily life what kind of
impact does it have a lot and it's it's
sort of scary
um
we all know that life is ephemeral
and spiritual Traditions have said wake
up to the fact that you know anything
that you do here is going to disappear
but it's even more ephemeral than
perhaps we've thought I see this model
because I create it right now as soon as
I look away
that data structure has been garbage
collected that bottle
I'll have to recreate it every time I
look so I spend all my money and I buy
this fancy car
that car I have to keep recreating it
every time I look at it it's that
ephemeral so all the things that we
invest ourselves in we fight over we
kill each other over and we have wars
over
these are all it's just like people in a
virtual reality simulation
right and and there's this this Porsche
and we all see the Porsche well what
that Porsche exists when I look at it I
turn my headset and I look at it and and
then if Joe turns his headset the right
way he'll see his Porsche but it's not
it's not even the same portion that I
see he's creating his own Porsche
so these things are exceedingly
ephemeral and and and now just imagine
saying that that's my Porsche well
you can agree to say that it's your
portion but but really the portion only
exists as long as you look so so this
all of a sudden what the spiritual
Traditions have been saying for a long
long time this gets cashed out in in
mathematically precise science it's
saying ephemeral yes in fact it lasts
for a few milliseconds a few hundred
milliseconds while you look at it and
then it's gone so so the whole idea
why are we fighting why do we hate
it's
we fight over possessions
because we we think that we're small
little objects inside this
pre-existing space time we assume that
that that mansion in that car exists
independent of us and that somehow we
these little things can have our sense
of self and importance enhanced by
having that special car or that special
house or that special person
what in fact is just the opposite you
create that Mansion every time you look
that's that's you're the You're
Something far deeper than that Mansion
you're the entity which can create that
mansion on the Fly and there's nothing
there there's nothing to the mansion
except what you create in this moment so
uh so all of a sudden when you take this
point of view
it has all sorts of implications for how
we can interact with each other how how
we treat each other
um
and again a lot of things that spiritual
Traditions have said
it's a mixed bag spiritual Traditions
are a mixed bag so let me just be right
up front about that I'm not promoting
any particular but they do have some
insights yeah they have wisdom they have
certain wisdom they have I can point to
nonsense I won't go into it but I can
also point to lots of nonsense so so the
the issue is to then to look for the
keys the key insights and they I think
they have a lot of insights about the
ephemeral nature of of objects in space
and time and not being attached to them
including our own bodies and reversing
that I'm not this little thing a little
Consciousness trapped in the body and
the Consciousness itself is only a
product of the body so when the body
dies the Consciousness disappears it
turns completely around the
Consciousness is fundamental the body
my hand exists right now because I'm
looking at it my hand is gone
I have no hand I have I have no brain I
have no heart if you looked you'll see a
heart
whatever I am
is this really complicated thing in
Consciousness that's that's what I am
all the stuff that I thought I was
something that I create on the Fly and
delete so this whole so this is
completely a radical restructuring of
how we think about
possessions about identity about
survival of death and and so forth this
is completely transformative but the
nice thing is that this whole approach
of consultations
unlike the spiritual Traditions which
have said in some cases similar things
they said it imprecisely
this is mathematics
we can actually now begin to stay
precisely here's the mathematical model
of Consciousness conscious agents here's
how it maps onto space-time which I
should sketch really briefly
and here's why
um
things are ephemeral and here's why you
shouldn't be worried about the ephemeral
nature of things because you're not a
little tiny entity inside space and time
quite the opposite you're the author of
space and time